this video is brought to you by
brilliant get a free trial with
brilliant to take advantage of its
hands-on stem learning lessons more
about them in a bit
he was the bisexual androgynous alien
rock god sent to earth to save us all at
the moment ziggy stardust first appeared
on british tv in 1971 the base of rock
and roll changed forever otherworldly
seductive and strangely alluring ziggy
not only helped kick off the glam rock
explosion but also mainstreamed a new
era of sexual and gender experimentation
had he been a real man his short period
of stardom would have been influential
enough to be talked about today but of
course this glitter messiah wasn't real
he was a character one of many from
aladdin sane to the thin white duke
who'd helped transform popular music in
europe and america the man behind these
characters was david bowie a
working-class kid from london bowie was
also a one-man artistic powerhouse
nominally a rock star his eclectic
dabblings in fashion video art and music
producing would turn out to be at least
as influential as his actual songs but
where did this master of reinvention
come from how did ordinary david jones
manage to turn himself into so many
extraordinary characters the answer lies
in the tale of a musician
unlike any other
if peggy jones had ever had any doubts
about her son being different from the
other boys they were likely dispelled
one day in 1950. walking in she found
three-year-old david buy her open
cosmetics bag trying without much
success to put on makeup disapproving
weary peggy tried to explain that boys
don't wear lipstick but her son simply
looked at her in confusion you do mummy
he said born on the 8th of january 1947
in the working class london district of
brixton david bowie's early life would
turn out to be filled with these sorts
of moments little snapshots of the
ever-changing otherworldly singer that
he'd one day become there was the
psychic midwife who at his birth
declared this child has been on earth
before there was the change of identity
he underwent before he was even a year
old as the boy born david robert burns
took his parents new married name
becoming his longest lived character
david jones there was the interest in
women's clothing and fashion the makeup
he stole from peggy but most
overwhelmingly of all dictating every
part of the boy's childhood was music
from his primary school days bowie was
obsessed with learning instruments with
perfecting his singing it was such an
all-consuming obsession that he even
turned down a place at the local grammar
school to instead study music at a
technical school by the time he was in
his mid-teens he could play saxophone
piano guitar and the ukulele yet bowie's
strange fascinations didn't stop at
music the paintings of german
expressionists mesmerized him as did the
jagged set design of fritz lang's 1927
sci-fi classic metropolis voraciously
reading on the subject the teenager
would soon develop a mad romantic
fascination with the city that birthed
the movement berlin and yes that was
absolutely a very smooth piece
foreshadowing by the time bowie
graduated high school in 1963 he was
musically trained and graced with an
otherworldly look in part thanks to his
whip-thin frame and pale skin and in
part thanks to a permanently donated
pupil the result of a schoolyard
punch-up that nearly blinded him he was
also ambitious over the next few years
he repeatedly joined or formed new bands
leaping between styles and genres the
only problem was that ambition was going
nowhere across the 1960s bowie released
multiple singles with multiple bands all
of which made even less impact than your
younger cousin's funny dance tik-tok
videos these failures were usually
followed by bowie immediately exiting
the band leaving behind unpaid debts and
a whole lot of pissed off people in his
wake still this era of failure was at
least giving him time to experiment time
to try on new guises new ways of looking
and acting some of this was clearly
personal such as bowie's increasing
tendency towards dressing in feminine
clothing or his developing relationship
with buddhism perhaps the major
spiritual influence in his life some of
it on the other hand was clearly just
done for attention such as when he went
on the bbc's tonight program claiming to
be president for the society for the
prevention of cruelty to long-haired men
his first ever tv appearance finally in
1965 he settled on the most lasting guys
of all that year david jones changed his
stage name to david bowie after the
bowie hunting knife at first there were
few signs this new persona would last
his 1967 debut album was an almost
legendary flop pulling in so few sales
that bowie briefly pivoted from music to
studying mine yet this latest change of
career wouldn't last within two short
years he would have returned
wholeheartedly to music and this time he
wouldn't stop until it made sure
everyone in britain knew the name david
bowie
the turn of the decade saw bowie
refining his sound slothing off the folk
tinged stuff something more rock
oriented these were the wilderness years
an era in which sales were mostly low
and critical attention mostly
non-existent but there were still signs
here and there that things might change
the biggest was space oddity a single
that introduced music fans to the lonely
astronaut major tom and it became
bowie's first actual hit sadly this
failed to translate into sales for the
accompanying album or its more rock
orientated follow up the man who sold
the world but while it must have been
frustrating putting out challenging work
only to be met with a universal shrug it
was bowie's personal life that was the
biggest source of pain in these years
between 1969 and 1970 came the one-two
punch of his father's death and his
half-brother terry burns being long-term
committed to a psychiatric hospital
mental ill health and addiction had
always run in the family his father had
been an alcoholic and now schizophrenia
had caught up with his brother bowie was
terrified it might come for him next
even nominally good things in this era
seem to be filled with poison in 1970
bowie married the model angie barnett
with whom he'd have a son duncan jones
they'd also have an open marriage like
bowie angie was bisexual and the two
initially delighted in being able to bed
other men and women before long though
this arrangement had turned as toxic as
the inside of chernobyl's reactor number
four bowie later claimed living with
angie was like living with a blowtorch
by 1971 then bowie was professionally
unfulfilled stalked by fears of mental
illness and embarking on the
relationship equivalent of the
hindenburg disaster the only solace must
have been the way his music continued to
evolve his third album hunky dory was
well underway a mix of pop serious rock
and callbacks to cabaret and musical
it's the album that would give the world
future classics like changes and life on
mars it was also the album where bowie
found his kooky esoteric voice nietzsche
references pop art shout outs and all
trouble was the general public still
wasn't buying it when hunky dory dropped
it'd be to rave reviews and
disappointing sales bowie might have
been finding his sound but he still
needed to find his audience it's at this
point that he hid on a plan that would
change british music forever in 1971
with hunky dory not yet released bowie
found himself working on two ideas the
first was to take his gigs to another
level away from being just some guys
with instruments and into a full sensory
experience more theater than concert the
other was something about the former
rocker vince taylor a one-time british
star taylor had wound up taking too many
drugs having a nervous breakdown and
declaring himself an alien god who'd
been
sent to earth as these two concepts
swirled around bowie's mind they slowly
began to merge into something he created
a character based on taylor a pansexual
alien rock star one who would come to
earth in its dying years with a message
of hope only to be destroyed
by his own ego he named the character
ziggy stardust after a taylor's shop
that he glimpsed from a train he
recruited some of the best musicians
he'd worked with on previous albums and
christened them the spiders from mars
this loose concept not yet fully settled
the band went into the studio that
november and recorded the bulk of the
album in just 10 days later other songs
would be added that fleshed out the
sci-fi and apocalypse themes but
recording was only half the work because
bowie already knew that he didn't want
ziggy to be another major tom just an
abstract character name checked in a
song no he wanted ziggy to be real so
real that david jones would vanish
sucked up into his mind leaving only
this alien presence his instinct would
turn out to be right when ziggy was
finally unleashed upon the world even
david bowie would have trouble
remembering which one of them was real
now if you don't want to have trouble
remembering important information then
good news today's video is sponsored by
brilliant brilliant for those who don't
already know is a website and app built
on the idea of active problem solving
because it takes more to learn something
than just watching it to really learn
something you have to do it which is why
brilliant has tons of lessons on its
platform for lifelong learners who
aren't content to just coast through
adulthood with the skills that they
learned at school for example have you
ever wanted to learn how computer
programming works but were put off or
intimidated by opaque coding language
brilliant can help you learn how to
program without having to dig deep
through the weeds of coding syntax
thanks to fun interactive challenges
brilliant users can shift around blocks
of pseudo code and then get immediate
feedback on their results it's an
engaging way to understand how computer
algorithms work and once you've got that
down the coding syntax becomes well a
lot less intimidating on brilliant it's
not about memorizing or regurgitating
facts for a test you could just pick a
course that you're interested in and get
started if you're feeling stuck or
afraid you made a mistake that's never
an issue you could read the explanation
to find out more and learn at your own
pace so if you're a lifelong viewer who
wants to give brilliant a try you guys
can get a free trial plus 20
off the cost of a year's subscription by
following the link in the description
below and now let's get back to today's
video
[Music]
for a generation of british youth one of
their defining moments came on the 6th
of july 1972. that evening kids across
the nation tuned in top of the pops not
to see yet another band play yet another
song but rather a visitor from another
world in full color bowie stood in the
middle of the stage his face white with
makeup dressed in a patterned gold red
blue suit somewhere between court jester
and sexy cosmonauts smiling and waving
and looking so fine as he appeared
seductively at the camera in the four or
so minutes it took him to belt out
starman a revolution was kick-started
one that would do for kids of the 1970s
what the beatles had done for their
older siblings a decade earlier yet for
bowie getting to this one fleeting
moment had been anything but easy the
amount of work that had gone into
ziggy's creation could be a video in and
of itself the winter of
1971-1972 had been spent in a fever
dream as bowie rushed to refine his new
character the costume ziggy and the
spiders would wear had taken months to
design getting the band to wear them had
taken longer still as guitarist mig
ronson later recalled his initial
response to the sparkly gold outfit had
been you can [ __ ] off i'm not wearing
that but slowly bowie had worn them down
had convinced them that the band had to
be so glam so out there that they'd make
mark bolan look like colin robinson at
the same time he was taking them to the
ballet telling them to observe the way
lighting was a part of the performance
as integral as anything happening on
stage behind the scenes he was
attracting press attention any way he
could in 1972 bowie famously came out as
gay in an interview with melody maker
the spider's next gig was sold out today
obviously there's something a little
queasy about this a non-gay man play
acting gay to increase ticket sales more
to the point his coming out announcement
really did help plenty of queer youth
struggling to survive in a britain where
gay love had been decriminalized only
five years earlier at a gig on the 29th
of january 1972 the ziggy phenomenon
finally came together on stage bowie was
becoming this alien erotic dancing with
male band members seductively licking
mick bronson's guitar freddie mercury
himself just a couple of years away from
stardom was at that gig he left bowled
over by what bowie was doing the final
piece of the puzzle came shortly after
unhappy with the record bowie had
delivered rca told him to go back and
write something they could mark it as a
single so the singer went and penced
starman after that everything was in
place the rise and fall of ziggy
stardust dropped on june the 16th two
weeks later london saw its first gay
pride march a week after that bowie and
the spiders went on top of the pops
apparently people at the bbc canteen
before the show mistook them for extras
from doctor who but there was no mistake
about what britain's youth saw starman
exploded amid a potent swirl of social
currents a glitter bomb dropped into the
drab economically depressed 1970s a
fabulous two fingers to homophobes
gender norms forget about famous
overnight bowie became a superstar in
just 3 minutes and 50 something seconds
it's almost impossible to overstate the
effect ziggy had in britain that year
bowie mania became the new beatle mania
an album sales sword on the streets
young straight working-class men were
suddenly sporting glitter and makeup and
glam was exploding in short it was a
phenomenon one pre-famed bowie could
have only dreamed of yeah within a year
it would all be over ziggy stardust
would be dead killed by his creator for
the man behind the costume though
this was only the beginning
[Music]
from our modern vantage point killing
ziggy stardust was probably bowie's best
career move starting the cycle of
reinvention that would power his
greatest work at the time though it
could have been fatal the news of
ziggy's 1973 demise spread like a shock
wave through the music scene especially
when bowie further declared falsely it
turned out that he would no longer tour
or play gigs only bo himself knew how
necessary the change was he knew how the
sudden fame had gone to his head
blurring the lines between ziggy
stardust and david jones he knew how in
a weird dark corner of his mind he'd
actually started to believe that he was
a messiah in this context killing ziggy
stardust was necessary for bowie's
mental health sadly his next phase would
tax his sanity even more there are two
ways of telling the story of david bowie
in the mid-1970s following his move to
los angeles the first is to focus on his
work on the succession of albums from
the iconic aladdin sane to the dark
orwell on acid vibe of diamond dogs
certainly this is a story worth telling
how bowie finally broke the u.s with his
plastic soul album young americans how
that evolved into the strange funk and
crouch-rock mix of station to station
how he took his first major movie role
playing an alien in the man he fell to
earth but it's the other side of the
story that's perhaps more revealing the
side simply titled breakdown the la is
or bowie gets so deep into drugs and
cocaine in particular that he lost all
grasp on reality constantly high bowie
almost stopped eating subsisting only on
milk and raw peppers he had periodic
overdoses began descending into an
intense paranoia that saw him store his
nail clippings in the fridge lest
witches try to steal them addiction had
always run in the family and now it had
gotten its claws into him in the
nastiest possible way as he vanished
into a haze white powder bowie's
interest started getting weirder and
weirder from nietzsche he moved into
dark magic and fascism began collecting
nazi memorabilia always someone who
tried to make his characters more than
just a stage presence he began to
constantly act the part of his latest
creation the thin white duke a loose
far-right aristocrat who sang passionate
lob songs while feeling nothing the duke
was even more alien than ziggy it was
reinhard heydrich resurrected and
repackaged for watergate america as with
ziggy bowie blurred the line between
himself and the duke culminating in
several wild interviews where he
declared i believe very strongly in
fascism and i believe britain could
benefit from a fascist leader years
later when the drug abuse was finally
behind him bowie would later offer
heartfelt apologies for those statements
in 1976 though at a time when the
neo-nazi national front was marching
across britain the damage was immense
bowie's apparent pro-fascism was one of
the key reasons rock against racism was
founded as that summit gave way to fall
david bowie was on a knife edge his
marriage failing so high he couldn't
even remember recording station to
station he claimed later of his mental
state it was like being in a car where
the steering had gone out of control and
you were going towards the edge of a
cliff whatever you did with the wheel it
was inevitable that you were going to go
over the edge i had almost resigned
myself to the fact that i was not going
to be able to stop and that would be it
clearly something needed to change if he
wasn't going to wind up dead a change of
scene a change of style anything that
might save him in the end that anything
would turn out to be getting out leaving
la behind and turning instead to a city
that had fascinated him ever since he
was a teenager david bowie was moving to
berlin
[Music]
the west berlin bowie arrived and
couldn't have been more different from
li a tiny oasis in a sea of communism
the berlin of the 1970s was a tense
weird place divided by a wall kept
artificially alive by western powers
half-empty yet crawling with spies it
was a city of militant leftists of cheap
rents and dive bars of artists and
students in short it was the perfect
place for a man driven mad by the
glamour and excess of la well eventually
when bowie first arrived with his friend
iggy pop and toe he kept straight on
with the bad habits the two took
astronomical amounts of drugs hit the
clubs and generally acted like the rock
stars that they were in one legendary
incident a coked up bowie drove in
circles around an underground car park
at 70 miles an hour screaming that he
was going to end it all by crashing into
a concrete pillar despite this false
start though the city soon worked its
magic part of the charm was that those
living in berlin couldn't give a [ __ ]
about david bowie he could walk the
streets effectively unrecognized just
another face in the crowd he began
dressing down reveling in his anonymity
he kicked the coke began exploring his
new home long bike rides going nowhere
in particular enjoying the freedom the
lack of urgency it wasn't long before
this transformation started showing up
in his work in berlin bowie reconnected
with his love of expressionism started
painting his own canvases now he told
his producer that he wanted to do
something similar with music mood pieces
he called his new songs he linked up
with branino the two exploring a kind of
sound unlike anything bowie had ever
done before the result was a low a
minimalist album a galaxy away from the
camp and glitter of ziggy stardust with
just 11 tracks only five of which have
any vocals low was a mission statement
from berlin a dreamy haunting notice
that rock's master of reinvention was
entering a new era more importantly it
showed bowie that he could still be
creative without the aid of drugs that
his writing wasn't contingent on
mind-altering substances as he later
said it was literally like being reborn
and it was an incredibly important
period for me i did see light at the end
of the tunnel and it wasn't a train
today low is considered a masterpiece
but in 1977 the public wasn't so sure
sales were middling instead it would be
the second berlin album that really
helped resurrect bowie the same year low
dropped bowie began working on its
follow-up like low it would feature dark
ambient songs with no vocals unlike its
predecessor though it would pepper this
electronic sound scrape with marketable
songs the most iconic of which would
give the album its name
heroes composed in the shadow of the
berlin wall heroes is simply one of
pop's masterpieces a love song laced
with irony recorded in an enormous dark
hall with three microphones placed
staggered distances from bowie as he
sang it sounds strange echoey and
utterly perfect needless to say the
record company were horrified they
considered the entire album a dark drab
mess less an act of creative liberation
than one of their most bankable stars
effectively taking a dump in their
wallets they begged him to change it to
do something more like young americans
but bowie insisted this was his going
clean album and he wanted it intact
heroes dropped in the tail end of 1977
just 10 months after low it's possible
no other rock star that decade released
two such perfect albums so close
together and this time the public
responded heroes was a critical and
commercial smash propelling bowie back
to the sharpest point of cutting-edge
music a vindication of everything he'd
done in berlin a sign that he could live
without addiction although he'd have
whole decades left as a successful
mega-selling artist his most
groundbreaking sales were now behind him
[Music]
so here we are the final chapter in this
video with nearly four decades of
bowie's life still to cover hopefully
you're not disappointed we only have
some 20 odd minutes with these things
and we decided early on it would be way
more illuminating to dive deeper into
ziggy stardust than the berliners than
to drag you through every half-decent
album that bowie released in the 80s and
90s the flip side of course is that now
we have to rush through the last bit
that means skipping stuff like his mega
selling collaboration with queen under
pressure or his role as the goblin king
in the classic movie labyrinth so strap
yourself in because this section is
going to be a high velocity ride
although heroes or possibly 1980 scary
monsters can be seen as the last great
gasp of bowie as a music changing artist
it certainly wasn't the end of his
commercial success the 1980s saw him
become a global mega star on par with
prince or michael jackson playing to
sold out arenas the apogee of this was
the release of let's dance and his
accompanying serious moonlight tour a
tour that not only made bowie millions
but also provided manga artist irie
karaki with the inspiration for his
infamous villain yoshikaja kira so yeah
it turns out that even david bowie's
life story is a goddamn jojo reference
the 1980s were also the era when a new
generation of music stars who'd grown up
inspired by bowie were emerging the kids
who'd seen ziggy singing starman all
those years before and never forgotten
it yet even as bowie's influence was
still shaping music the man himself was
losing his touch after the hyper success
of let's dance a string of disappointing
projects followed from the hard rock tin
machine to the abysmal mess of 1987's
never let me down even as the money
rolled in it was clear something had
changed bowie was still capable of
producing catchy music still capable of
experimenting but the creativity of
berlin of ziggy stardust even of the
plastic soul era was gone bowie would
remain a rock icon but never again would
he shape popular music the way he once
had still that's not to say this period
was uneventful there was beau's marriage
to the somali-american model iman abdul
majid in 1992 then moved to new york his
reclusive nature after the pair's
daughter was born as he tried to keep
his second child out of the spotlight
there was two the selling out like the
time he found in an online bank called
bowie bank offering credit cards with
his picture on them but there were also
the tender moments the concert he helped
organized in his adopted city in the
aftermath of 9 11 where he touchingly
sang heroes to a crowd still raw with
grief finally though in 2004 bowie's
performing career ended for good while
on tour in germany the singer started
experiencing chest pains hospitalized he
underwent emergency surgery in the wake
of the near heart attack bowie stopped
touring retreated into the background
even as he continued to produce new
music acts yet even in semi-retirement
his ability to shock wasn't quite gone
in 2013 after a 10-year drought bowie
suddenly released a whole new album
online that had been recorded in secret
known as the next day it proved the 66
year old rocker was still capable of
captivating the music press but it was
what came three years later that really
changed things on january 8 2016 another
secretly recorded album appeared without
warning but while the next day had been
newsworthy mostly for being a surprise a
melancholy pared down thing of beauty
that was more experimental jazz than a
rock album it seemed the master of
reinvention had done it again producing
a late period album as left field and
perhaps as beautiful as low sadly it
would wind up being an epitaph david
bowie died two days after black star
came out the victim of liver cancer that
had been keeping secret from all but his
closest family in the aftermath of his
death impromptu memorial sprang up
across the cities it lived in
spontaneous outpourings of grief in new
york london and of course berlin his
ashes were scattered days later in a
buddhist ritual held in bali one final
goodbye to the earth that his creation
ziggy had traveled so far to see looking
back from the here and now it's almost
impossible to untangle bow's effect on
music and culture so pervasive was his
influence he was a pioneer who shaped
glam rock and early electronica a singer
who helped mainstream soul a performer
who upended fashion and who changed what
concerts could be his private life was
groundbreaking too while coming out as a
gay man may have been a marketing ploy
he was still an openly queer man when he
confirmed his bisexuality in 1976 he was
the first major entertainer to publicly
identify us by beyond all that though
bowie's greatest legacy may have been
his fans multiple generations of
ordinary folk heard his music and were
inspired millions of fat skinny people
of tall short people millions who heard
his music like an alien signal from some
far-off beautiful planet telling them
they were not alone every generation has
its music stars who seemed to capture
the feeling of the times for those
coming of age in the 1960s it was the
beatles for kids today it might be billy
eilish or lil nas x but for anyone who
heard his voice at the right age their
personal hero will always be david bowie
the singer who fell to earth
so i really hope you found that video
interesting if you did please do hit
that thumbs up button below don't forget
to subscribe and thank you for watching
[Music]
you